l'étoile a différé la la petite soeur
jody bagarre hier donc jt c'est ton
pseudo
j'ai trouvé ça tellement doux j'avais
jamais rien vu de pareil
le mec là ces kits nava tard j'étais
vraiment pas bien quand j'ai écrit ça il
ya quelque chose qui qui s'est emparée
de moi à oui il a commencé à me raconter
sa vie histoire préhistoire j'ai tout
écrit j'en ai fait un livre qui est
devenu un best-seller dans les teams
jeans avec ces thèmes ont agité les
rails jti ne se sent pas bien alors je
dois vous dire à mon grand regret que
finalement il sera pas là ce soir avait
dit je me demandais si je pourrais de
prendre en photo pour que ça lui serve
de portraits quoi comment commencer que
je veux dire moi je suis une fille tu
vois ce que je veux dire je sais que
c'est évident
la vigie toi quand on présente quelqu'un
lui remet jamais en question son
identité
est très bon
gpm je crois qu'il en a c'est pourquoi
mais j'ai eu le temps de faire q tel que
vous ne vous rendez pas compte des deux
doigts d quand je suis entré une
productrice de niveau équivalent
[Musique]
c'est qu'en tant que tu sois là ouais
excusez-moi de vous interroger tenait
seulement dire à quel point ces livres
sont importants pour moi
vécu dans l'âme et moi aussi pendant un
moment il est vachement réel pour plein
de gens
tu devrais écrire sous ton proprement
fait témoin cet ado alors oui tout ça
c'est bien réel
dis moi que tu as écrit serment et que
tu veux bien la personne que tu devrais
te m je pense que j'étais la personne
que dieu qu'elle soit on nous donne ces
personnalités et on nous donne cette
enveloppe physique on peut souffrir le
martyre a essayé de les obliger à
correspondre où on peut se créer notre
propre rire
j'ai l'impression de faire quelque chose
j'adore ce sentiment ça fait des années
que je voulais le trouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en séance ce n'est pas parce que tu es
génial écrivain dans l'est forcément à
[Musique]